let's just we're gonna completely jump
off the cliff on this story and just
move on to politics we have this one
from Fox News Karine Jean-Pierre spars
with reporters refuses to answer Hunter
Biden questions in testy exchanges
although it's interesting because the
way it was described to me is that the
the Press Corps has completely turned on
the Biden Administration I mean Ian and
Benny were both like it was bad dude we
should watch part at least part of the
four minute video of the reporters one
after the other picking up where the
other one left off creamy like I'm not
answering that question you what do you
want and they're like well I just want
to continue with their question she's
like I'm not answering it okay you and
he's like I want to continue with the
the old reporters it was stunning but
you were saying many that they're like
they're done with them and this is
they're getting pushed out because the
there's the hunter Biden story and then
there was more importantly the uh the
Ocean Ocean Gate Scandal where
apparently the government knew for a
week that this sub had likely imploded
and they didn't tell anybody the this is
the this is our federal government's
version of uh the 66. Joe Biden's
getting Order 66 right now if you see it
you'll never be able to unsee it follow
some of the New York Times writers
follow some of the Washington Post
writers follow Chuck Todd we have to do
it professionally I would never
recommend you do these things because
you'll never get anything useful what
you'll see is the order has gone out you
are now allowed to attack
you are now allowed to ask your question
why does Chuck Todd after three years
Chuck Todd finally finds this story
interesting and he leads NBC Nightly
News with a seven minute episode on this
CNN's reporter at the White House
was the one who's the most Savage in
this video that we're gonna watch
hopefully uh to Karen Jean Pierre oh
yeah CNN New York Times NBC News they're
all ganging up on Biden nah man or 66
went out let's play this clip here we go
oh it's not working what's going on
I'm wondering if you could take us into
the thinking and the decision making of
why you're not asking this question I'm
just not going to get into family
discussion personal family discussion as
you know Hunter is his son I'm just not
going to get into this if Hunter Biden
wasn't the president's son would he have
invited someone who had just reached the
plea agreement with Federal prosecutors
a couple of things again that's his son
it's a he's a fan ber it is common for
family members to attend events at the
White House you could look at past
presidents I'm sure you have so that is
let's jump ahead so here's the thing and
I appreciate the United States Who's
involved as this message to you suggest
in some sort of a coercive conversation
for business dealing by Asana is that
something so this is they're referring
to this text that went out where what
Hunter was basically like I'm sitting
here with the big guy right now and
we'll put all our Force against unless
you do it he says I'm sitting here with
my father and he says it twice in the
text multiple times yeah uh it's a
WhatsApp text and it has not been
refuted this text seems legitimate so
his lawyer responded to the text today
confirming Hunter Biden's lawyer
responded to the text confirming that it
was a legitimate text that the text is
real to the Communist Chinese
apparatchik wow and what was the defense
oh my client was on drugs at the time
sitting next time
so uh this morning we did the first of
our uh new so the idea for the culture
War show was always to be like having
the debates that we sometimes have on
IRL but don't fit the format we do
topical news here having someone on
who's going to debate turns into a
debate show so Friday morning will be we
had on Emma vigiland and one of the
conversations we had was me saying I
don't quite understand why there are so
many people on the left who don't like
Joe Biden but will absolutely defend him
on these scandals instead of just saying
sure
and for some reason we got into the
argument and this uh this individual she
was very much like I don't think it's
real the barisma stuff's not true you
know there's no evidence to prove it
shokin was not investigating
I'm like I just he was like I don't
understand but now I'm wondering if if
they're going to change tune these uh
these these Lefty types now that we're
seeing the signal flare has gone up it
is now open season to to go after Joe
Biden on the on the corruption Scandal I
think so this is I was like this is one
of the most jaw-dropping pieces of news
media I've ever seen in my life I mean
it is it is incred anyone that cares or
has been following the hunter Biden
scandal the stuff with barisma anyone
over the last three to four years watch
this video watch it from start to finish
You're Gonna Want More when it ends I
don't know if they they only got three
and a half out of her but I mean this is
a tactic that can be continued to you be
used by the news media until forbid they
were supposed to
it's right they're supposed to ask about
these stories but it's but this is the
point I was bringing up in the in the in
the debate show I'm like how about if
you don't know whether or not Joe Biden
did or did not engage in a quid pro quo
you just say yeah I don't know enough
about that but I don't like Biden so I'm
not going to give him the benefit of the
doubt how about you just say I'm not
going to comment for some reason there's
this adamant need among these left
personalities like I'm not talking about
liberals either like leftists we'll be
like I don't like Joe Biden I won't
defend him but this story is not true
and I'm like you don't know anything
about the story why are you defending
him this is what we see it is it is the
establishment narrative line it is it is
you are not approved the New York Times
can come out how about this Politico
magazine can come out outright be like
the Biden family uh Fortune has tracked
perfectly alongside Biden's career in
government his brother getting contracts
to do construction in Iraq things like
this they political made a timeline of
it and then they come out and say never
happened and I'm like I just don't
understand this need to be like nothing
to see here nothing to see here Biden's
perfect now all all of a sudden with the
corporate narrative shifting probably
because they don't want Biden for 2024
now I'm wondering if we'll see these
left personalities be like we never
liked Biden what are you talking about
that's exactly what's going to end up
happening because they consider the
mainstream narrative to be their kind of
God in a lot of ways they don't know how
to see things through any other lens
because they track anything else as
propaganda and anything else's uh
anti-establishment which gets a label of
being
like it's against them inherently you
can't ask questions honestly they don't
think you're asking your questions
honestly they think you're asking your
questions to trap them in something
because you have your own agenda rather
than the agenda of just wanting to know
what the hell is going on that's a cult
bro yeah yeah it's because you're evil
and you brought it up and right Wingers
brought up that barisma tape thing so
like therefore it has to be invalid and
you know you've asked two people about
this on air and they haven't seen the
video which is fascinating yeah every
time we ask a liberal or left
personality about the uh quid pro quo
Joe Biden thing fire the prosecutor
knocking the billion dollars this I've
never heard of that yeah or they say
it's RT it's RT so it's not reliable
because that was just a clip from the
CFR I was like oh there's a C-SPAN yeah
yeah but if you want to see that clip
Now isn't that on like RT what's on
Twitter yeah the behavior isn't
necessarily uh all solely on the left uh
the react it's a reactionary behavior
and you can get it from people that are
are either it kind of comes from Fear I
mean that's a vague term but like people
that are afraid to be trapped I think
for sure I think that's a big part of it
is like people like you they feel like
you're about to lead them into a corner
where they don't have enough information
and so their inherent reaction is to
just lash out plus they've had a lot of
things held from them for the last two
years three years after all the social
media networks made sure you didn't know
what was going on with Hunter Biden made
sure you didn't know what was going on
with Prisma I know plenty of people who
just don't even know what that is who
don't know anything that's going on
there it's because but for a public
figure an online figure agreeing with
somebody on the right or the people who
shared that barisma video is worse than
the hypocrisy because who's going to
call them out of the Democracy only
people that they perceive to be more on
the right than that that's a cult so
like they don't see this clip like again
people prominent news cover headline
news and politics on a daily basis come
on and they say I've never seen that
clip you had the show with Hunter where
he said that clip doesn't exist and then
you actually smarter was like that never
happened yeah and I was like let me pull
the clip up for you and you can watch it
happen like I don't understand and he
didn't he didn't know and for him for
him that might be fair because he does
more cultural stuff and he admits that
but like for her and she does
presidential politics on a daily basis
and she's like I've never watched the
clip it's it's it's a question of
why Hunter said that never happened
instead of just being like I'm not
familiar with that but I'm not going to
defend Joe Biden Yes
actually oh man this just happened
Keith obermann saying that Hillary
Clinton never smashed her cell phones he
just got destroyed Nancy mace tweeted
Nancy made this just happened online for
all of us to see and he got community
noted into the sun on Twitter Nancy mace
goes well it's a tweet and right please
feel free because it's awesome it's the
best community note ever he's like you
know that didn't happen right yeah Nancy
May's like Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
gets arrested right a classified
document thing Nancy made this guy yo
Hillary deleted all these emails and
then smashed all of her phones with a
hammer and Keith overen says that never
happened duh that's just lying
it like a couple days ago or what
um it was at least a week ago now like
that the thing is about that is that's
just bad faith they're doing that
because they know that they have large
audiences and there's no way they're
going to agree to what you said because
that tweet then lasts forever so they're
just lying because it's beneficial to
them Community noted uh uh uh through
like through the stratosphere with all
these links including a CNN fact check
which is the greatest CNN fact check to
ever air ever on any the probably the
best 60 seconds to ever air on any cable
news ever where CNN had to get fact
checked on air that Hillary Clinton did
in fact smash all of her devices with a
hammer that was from their supreme court
reporters
classic have you seen the fact check
from one of these websites on that
specifically it's that Hillary Clinton
destroyed her devices and they were
destroyed with a hammer but she had a
staffer do it therefore it's like mostly
false right right
she didn't ask
words are all
it's like when you make a claim it's you
better be the most specific as humanly
possible otherwise you're a liar but
they can make any general claim and then
it's like well you know it's obviously
true about you though like you are
especially if they're accusing you of
something you're right about specific it
is so important in this age of if you
think we're in a culture war that you
use the right words that you are very
specific and then Hillary Clinton no I'm
sorry a Hillary Clinton staffer then
took a hammer it was a this ounce hammer
and they smashed it on the ground you
have to literally say the exact thing
otherwise they're going to use that
because they know they don't care if
people read the fact check they just
want people to see that there's a fact
checks on it false partially false
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time